[Music]
hey guys it's a uh cold rainy day here
in Fresno and I just came back from
driving around and I took a corner
really fast and everything's really wet
right now and uh my tires had just
enough grip to allow me to make a pretty
quick turn and and when after I made the
turn I thought about how happy I was
that there was plenty of tread on my
tires so it enabled me to kind of to get
the grip I needed to make that turn and
that started to make me think about uh
race car tires and regular daily driver
tires and how they differ and and they
differ for very important reasons and
that led me to think about martial arts
and self-defense and Sport martial arts
and how that works um and I know that
seems strange probably to think about
all those things in a row but I think
about martial arts most of the time so
usually any anything I I kind of start
to understand I I start to equate to
martial arts really quickly so real
briefly and it it tires really don't
matter to most the people watching this
video I'm sure but basically uh your
Tire's job is to make a lot of
connection to the ground right so you
want a lot of surface area to make
connection to the ground now in a race
car tire they use a really slick tread
and the reason they do this is because
the Slick tread allows you to make
maximum uh contact surface area with the
track and the track's a consistent
surface that we always know about so
it's always hard and smooth and grippy
and and we we can always make sure we
have our races when the tire or when the
conditions are optimal for the tire to
grip right so for example if it's rainy
uh or it's too cold and the track's kind
of hard and frosty or it's too hot and
the track's kind of gummy we can say oh
we're not going to have a race today
because the conditions aren't right and
so it's not safe or not ideal for for
racing in a normal cars Tire we have
tread on our tires and the reason we
have that tread is because when the the
surface that we're driving on is soft or
loose or by loose I mean like there's a
lot of grit that can slide around or
something like that uh so like dust or
rain uh or if it's really slick we need
surface area we need more surface area
to catch as the tire slides along right
so if you can picture it you know the
Bottom's of course always connecting but
if the bottom gives way we want to have
little ridges that can kind of catch any
bumps along the way that get us to have
more traction so the the everyday driver
tire kind of makes a sacrifice of not
having optimal traction on on a perfect
roadway but when the roadway is not
perfect it gives us a lot of traction
that we wouldn't have in a slick tire
and that's of course probably not
important to most of you but it makes a
nice analogy for me with the martial
arts in the martial arts if you're
studying martial arts for self-defense
and that is that you want to have a
pragmatic ability to take care of
yourself when you're out in the world
you need to have the equivalent of a
general purpose allterrain tire so you
want a tire with a lot of ridges so when
the the the ground gives way on you
right in a martial context this is when
the fighting doesn't go the way you
expected it to uh you have a lot more
surface area in between that'll catch
little bumps right so those each each
martial art you study kind of gives you
ridges in your tire so you understand a
broader field of
study uh whereas a sport uh martial art
is kind of like a slick track tire uh
for racing where it's built to optimally
catch the surface we're expecting right
so there's a surface we're expecting to
be on and this flat tire completely
makes contact so you get more surface
area in that respect how is this
important to us if you're studying
something like say Western boxing
Western boxing is a sport martial art
that is specially designed to understand
what happens in a situation where two
humans are only trying to strike each
other and only trying to strike each
other with the ends of their arms so
their fists are the only things we're
making contact with that martial art is
an absolute perfect martial art for
understanding the that kind of context
we're talking about just
fighting Western boxers are
masters of that kind of context and you
could not ask for a better system to
learn to deal with that kind of
stuff but the world is not always going
to be a boxing match right right
sometimes people are going to try to
wrestle with you so the sport martial
art of boxing has a hard time dealing
with Grapplers because it doesn't train
against those guys a lot now that's not
a necessary kind of training
for boxing but it is a necessary kind of
training for overall self-defense
because someone might try to Grapple
with you you don't know the surface that
you're always going to be on so you need
to have lots of different abilities to
to handle different things uh sport
martial arts are really good at talking
about one kind of thing and what they do
is they isol ol at that thing and make
us really good they give us a way to
practice over and over and over that one
isolated environment if you're studying
martial arts for self-defense you can't
expect that any one of those isolated
environments is going to be good for
your training because it's just like a
slick track now if the conditions are
ideal if you're in a a boxing match and
you're a sport boxer then it's that's
going to be great for you but when it's
rainy or Dusty or the equivalent of some
kind of different condition you're not
going to be able to handle it very well
and you're not going to understand how
to apply those boxing skills in all the
different terrains because you've
limited and isolated your training to
one small bracket uh it's important for
people interested in self-defense to
study sport martial arts but you must be
a generalist when you're studying
martial arts for self-defense because
you don't know what kind of environment
you're going to be in you might be on
the top of a mountain or in the dark or
in a mall or in your car who knows you
could be in all kinds of environments
and so you need to be a generalist to be
able to handle all these different types
of events that that could happen so for
example if you ended up in a fight on
the ground you're going to need some
kind of ground grappling martial art
like say Brazilian jiu-jitsu then a lot
of people who study self-defense will
say well I don't want to stay Brazilian
Jitsu because I don't want to fight on
the ground and that's a correct
statement you don't want to fight on the
ground but you might find yourself on
the ground so if we go back to our
analogy of the tire you know as as a guy
who drives cars I can say well will
ideally always want to drive on a
perfect track and you do but sometimes
you have to go off terrain because
that's what happens right when we're
driving every day we don't always get to
drive in the absolute perfect
environment so we want a tire that can
handle different environments and
likewise we want our training to be able
to handle different kinds of
environments uh and the kinds of
environments you're going to face are
really wide and one of the biggest
problems with studying sport martial
arts and Sport martial arts only is you
don't open up your mind to the different
types of contexts you're going to be
facing so it's very likely you're going
to be in in some kind of weapon
situation if you only study sport
martial arts when a weapon comes into
play you don't really have many ideas
about how to deal with the weapon you're
also almost never going to be in the
ideal condition that you're training in
in a sport martial art right you could
be training on unlevel ground or on
grass or a knee deep in the water or all
kinds of environments can change and if
you don't take this into into
consideration in your training you're
not going to be ready for it when it
happens so a lot of times when I talk
about the problems with sport martial
arts I think people get the wrong idea
sport Mars are excellent Avenues of
study but you have to realize that when
you're studying them you're only setting
one isolated piece even in something
like mix martial arts that people feel
like is such a complete martial arts
it's it's a great thing to study because
you learn how to box and you learn how
to Grapple you learn how to Grapple on
the ground and that's it's just such a
complete method of fighting but it's
really still a very very small chunk
when you consider um that mixed martial
arts doesn't take into account any kind
of environmental changes it doesn't take
into account any kind of weapon conflict
it doesn't take into account multiple
attacker situations so that's that's an
awful lot of area that it's just
completely
ignoring that's not to say that sport
martial arts aren't really good at what
they do they're better at what they do
um in that specific situation than any
generalist could even be generally
because the when when you're looking at
a lot of different environments it's
hard to master any one of those
environments and so you know something
like uh Western boxing is really good at
handling uh what happens when someone
strikes me or when I try to strike
someone else uh the problem with it is
it just it doesn't have any clue about
what to do with other situations so
you've got to study several different
situations you should study some sport
martial arts if you're interested in
self-defense because they're excellent
at dealing with their isolated Avenue
but you have to keep your mind open to
all the different Avenues of study that
that you need to have because if you
don't do that you're completely
surprised when something different
happens if you think the world is all
standup boxing the first time someone uh
kicks you that's a shock the first time
someone grabs your legs and takes you
down that's a shock the first time
someone pulls out a knife or a stick and
hits you with it that's a shock so all
these things are are are surprising to
you and you don't quite know how to
apply your your basic skills in these
different situations so if you're study
martial arts for self-defense you need
to be more of a generalist and less of a
specialist you want to develop that
allterrain Tire if you will as opposed
to a sport slick which is designed for
for one objective only so I hope this
kind of odd analogy helps some of you
with your thinking about martial arts
training and self-defense I'm Chris H
this is iido of Fresno keep training